Selamlar dostlar. Umarım iyisinizdir.
Öncelikle hepinizin bayramını kutlarım.
Allah sevdiklerinizle birlikte özellikle
ailenizle, anne babanızla,
kardeşlerinizle birlikte umarım nice
güzel bayramlar nasip eder sizlere.
Tipik her zamanki gibi bayramlar. Özel
zamanlarda bir Vonzinle yıllardır olduğu
gibi yine bir içerikte bugün Refactoric
Master Class serisine devam ediyoruz. Bu
sefer arkadaşlar özellikle benim en çok
önem verdiğim size network manager ve
model arkitektörünü anlatıyor olacağım.
Bu videoda neler bulacaksınız? E bu
videonun içerisinde size network manager
katmanında yaptığım kendi de paketim
olan Vegana Vegana ile birlikte generic
network manager katmanı kurmayı
öğreteceğim. Bunun üzerinden size model
yapısını anlatıyor olacağım. Bunları
yaparken model üretiminin generation'ını
bağlayacağım ve tabii ki de günün
sonunda her videonun sonunda yaptığım
gibi bir prompt veriyor olacağım ve bir
de üzerine vereceğim commandlarla siz de
çok rahatlıkla birlikte bu fikri, bu
yapıyı alıp projelerinizde
kullanabilecek halde sunuyor olacağım.
Yani herhangi bir yeni projeye
başladığınızda çok rahat bir şekilde
network katmanını işte bunun
modellerini,
promptunu işte olması gereken
practislerini, kullanımlarını çok hızlı
bir şekilde e entegre ediyor olacaksınız
projenize. Eee ondan dolayı aslında çok
önemli ve çok değerli bir eee her
zamanki gibi benim anlattıklarım böyle
de eee içerik şu an sizle birlikte
geliyor olacak.
Şimdi gelelim bizim kısmımıza. Benim
için özellikle bu video bir kısımla şu
kısım çok önemli. E bu benim babamın
olmadığı ilk bayram. Eee içimde çok
böyle farklı şeyler de var aslında ama
eee ben hep ondan öğrendiğim daima eee
gençlere işte geleceğe sahip çıkmak, bir
şeyler katabilmek, insanlara hani bunu
da sevgiyle illa içerisinde onu çıkar
olmadan ki kanalda yıllardır bunu
yapıyorum. Bugün de bu kadar zor
olmasına rağmen açıkçası benim için ilk
o ilk olmasından dolayı da e yine de
burada olmayı tercih ettim ki hani eee o
kavgayı devam ettirmek lazım. Buradan
hem onun adına hem onun gibi yine benim
gibi bunu yaşayanlar babasını ya da
kardeşini sevdiğini kaybetmiş herkes
adına Allah'tan rahmet diliyorum. Umarım
bizleri görüyor, duyuyorlardır ve güzel
bir şekilde, mutlu bir şekilde bizleri
anıyorlardır diyeyim. Eee, kendilerine
hepsine sevgilerimi iletiyorum. E,
öpüyorum. Yani sizlerin de ellerinden,
büyüklerimin, önünden, küçük hepsini
öpüyorum. Hayırlı bayramlar dileyeyim.
Neyse o kenarımızda kalsın. Hayatı devam
ettireceğiz. Devam ettireceğiz. Zor da
olsa devam ettireceğiz. Şimdi arkadaşlar
geliyoruz dediğim gibi network manager
katmanına. Şimdi network manager
katmanında size ben kurduğum bu
arkitektör mimariyi tabii ki artık
sıfırdan anlatmayacağım. Çünkü e bunlar
artık defalarca kanalda anlattığım
şeyler olduğu için ben size böyle bir
proje yaptığınızda diyelim ki mesela
burada var zaten. Şimdi göstereceğim
mesela şuradan bir başlatayım. Bir
önceki snapshot'ını da size gösteriyor
olacağım. Şimdi fork'tan gideyim mesela
şu 35 changes'tan önce arkadaşlar şurada
benim değiştirdiğim dosyalardan bir
tanesi. Mesela home sayfama gidiyor
olayım. Mesela nerede vardı? Şu profile
page'de vardı. Bakın bir önceki
kullanımda işte doğrudan mesela bir duo
instance'ını kullanıp DIO instanceından
projenize işte network katmanını entegre
edip buradan şöyle getlerini atıp bu
get'leri de işte çeşitli kodlarla burada
mesela bir örneği fake yapmış bunu geçti
mesela şu flight liste var işte ilgili
şuraya atıyor hiçbir constant yok bir
şey yok böyle yazılı kontrol mekanizması
yok ve en önemli konu mesela network
managerızı oluşturdunuz veya network
katmanı yani internete istek atacağınız
şeyleri oluşturdunuz internetsiz
deneyemediğiniz bir senaryo olamaz tamam
Tamam bu internet bağımlılığı olan bir
kısım. Bununla ilgili derdiniz yok ama
bir kodunuzun illa internetle çalışır
diyememe yani kodu yazan kişi bunu
dememeli. O kodun aslında internet kısmı
bir bağımlılık ve bağımlılıkları da
yönetiyor olmamız lazım. Bununla ilgili
işte depend inversionlar, depend
injectionlar çeşitli kavramlar girer.
Ama biz bunları burada daha basit
inceliyor olacağız. Buradaki amacımız
bunların da dışında herhangi bir
projede, herhangi bir anda yazacağınız o
internetleri network yani o istekleri
yönetecek katmanın eee gelişebilir,
değişebilir ve kolaylıkla adapte edileb.
Ondan dolayı mesela şu tarz kullanımlar
işte statüs kodlar, bunların yönetimi ve
her dosyada tekrar tekrar yazmak gibi
işlerden sizi kurtaracak çok önemli bir
aslında anlatımda bulunuyor olacağım.
Bir de burada yine size anlatacağım
ikinci kısımsa bu tarz bir projelerde en
çok önemli kısımlardan bir tanesi bu
modellerdir. Çünkü modeller yüzlerce
modeliniz olabilir projede ve bu
modelleri tek yazmak gerçekten çok eee
zaman kaybı ve eee şeyi kaybettirir.
Stabilityyi kaybettirir. Çünkü yeni
modelle bir şey gelebilir. Biri
değiştirebilir, bir şeyler yapabilir.
Bunlarla ilgili de kod generation
paketleri çok aktif kullanılıyor
sektörde herkesin. Eee, burada ben en
başlangıç sev yani olma başlangıç de
olması gereken zaten bu phonilizable'la
bir de table eklentisiyle immutable hem
de generation'ları bu timede oluşan
güzel bir yapıyı sizlere veriyor
olacağım. Yani artık bizim şöyle mesela
eskisi gibi şöyle bir kodumuz olmayacak.
Bir mimari yaklaşım şeklinde kodumuz
olacak ve buradan yakalıyor olacağız.
Eee, son olarak arkadaşlar test
classlarını göstereceğim. Ufak test
mimarileri yazdım. E bir de burada size
aktaracağım build yamal kısmıyla da
konuyu aslında güzel bir şekilde
tamamlayacağız. Şimdi arkadaşlar burada
da promptlarım var. Onları da ufak
anlatacağım dediğim gibi hızlı hızlı ya
çünkü bunlar bunlar artık A generated'ın
da verdiği destekle birlikte bunları
sıfırdan yazmadan sakin bir şekilde size
bunları aktarıyor olacağım. Bunların
promptü ve zaten eee commandları size
geliyor olacak. Şimdi arkadaşlar benim
dediğim gibi temel amacım demin size
anlattım. Bir projede olmazsa olmaz
nokta sizin o istekleri veya yapıları
merkezi noktadan yönetmenizdir. Bu
merkezi noktayı bir şekilde kurarsınız.
Bunu ister giderseniz Flutter'ın kendi
paketleri diile kurarsınız ya da sizin
yazacağınız ara paketlerle veya mesela
benim Vegana paketimle. Benim Vegana
paketim burada size kattığı şey ne? E
araya yazdığım bir network manager
aslında var ve bu bu bir strateji
paternile kullanılır. Çok rahatlıkla
geliştirebilir. İçerisine eklem
yapabilir ve içerisindeki verdiğim
ekstra şeylerle eee çok basit bir
şekilde kodunuzun verdiğiniz attığınız
servis isteklerinin cevaplarını alıp
handle alıp yönetebilirsiniz. Mesela
neden bahsediyorum? Mesela normalde bir
istek attığınızda gidersiniz dersiniz ki
işte bu size ne döndü, şöyle mi döndü,
böyle mi döndü vesaire değil yaparsınız
ama aslında temel hep aynıdır. On error
durum budur. Bunun ikisinden birine
düşürecektir daima. Bu noktaya
arkadaşlar bizim şu anki network manager
yani benim yaptığım bu veganı kullanıp
mimaride oluşturduğunuzda şu şekilde
kullanıyorsunuz. Mesela authentication
service.login diyorsun. Login deyince
sana bir result ve sealed bir obje
dönüyor. Result şeklinde. Bunu fold
diyerek on success scopunua ons'i
yapıyorsun. On error scopunua da on
error yapıyorsun. Bu kullanım şu an eee
en aktif ve arkadaşlarla zamanda entegre
ettiğimiz kullanım. İster böyle
kullanırsınız ister içerisinde başka
kullanımlar da eski kullanım da var onu
da kullanırsınız. Bu yaklaşımı size
bırakıyorum. Burada bir mimari yaklaşım
var. Buna göre seçeceksiniz. Şimdi
buradaki temel bakış arkadaşlar benim
network manager da şimdi network
managerın içerisine gidecek olacak
olursak benim bir tane aslında projenin
her yerinde kullanacak ve projenin
içerisindeki alt sınıflarında alacağı
bir product network managerım var. Bunun
içerisinde de benim temel olarak bir
statik yaptığım bunu ileride kontainer
içerisine koyacağım bir instance'ım var.
içerisinde temel kullandığım işte
instance resetleme setup gibi. Setup
benim genel olarak yine projelerde
koyduğum base urlaya koyacağım
strafault'ta verme yeri olarak
düşünebilirsiniz. Bunları set ediyorum.
Burada bir send request ekstra metot
yazdı. Bunu yazmasına gerek yoktu ama
hani kendisi de yönetimde böyle bir şeye
girdi. Bunu da kullanabilirsiniz. Günün
sonunda aslında ben bu product network
manager katmanında sizin de yapacağınız
ve yine prompt üreteceğinizde işte set
authentication token. Authentication
tokenı bir kere set edip bütün projeleri
bir daha kullanmadan önemli nokt
edersin. Bir daha her yerde set edilmez
bu. Bir kere kullanılacak ve diğerleri
de oradan alacak. Logout olduğunda
buradan sileceğiz. İşte authenticated
checkerları base headera, property
mesela her base headerda versiyon
numarası vesaire bunları product network
manager kasıla çok rahat yönetebilir
halde olacaksınız. Bizim temel
prensibimiz bu. Şimdi ben diyelim ki
product network managerımı kurdum hocam.
Ondan sonra ben diyelim flight servisim
yani ben mesela flight'ları çekeceğim.
Yani bütün hepsini alacağım. O noktada
sizin temel yaklaşım olarak benim en
sevdiğim şey bunu bir abstrak classile
yapmak, soyutlamak. Çünkü sen eğer bu
klassını soyutlarsan ve yarın bir gün
yani bunlar tabii büyük projelerde
başınıza gelir. Hani normal ortak küçük
projelerde karşınıza gelmez ama ben yine
onu anlatayım. Siz oradan referans alın.
Bunu stra yaparsan yarın herhangi bir
katmanda çok rahat bir şekilde bunun
içerisindeki metotları bir network
manager değiştirirsin, bir şey koyarsın,
çok rahat oynatabilirsin oyununu ama
doğrudan cllassı verirsen klasın
içerisinde yapacağın o bağ kullanımları
değiştirmen zor olacaktır ve eee bu
noktada işte çeşitli sorular karşına
çıkabilir. Ondan dolayı soyutlayarak
kullanıyorum ki burada mesela burada
flight ı flight service gibi bunun
implementasyon dosyasına gittiğimde
arkadaşlar mesela flight servisin
içerisini ben doldurmuşum. İsteklerimi
bu şekilde atıp getirmişim. Şimdi burada
mesela flight servisimin içerisinde
önemli dikkat etm gerekirken sizin de
yapmanız gereken herhangi bir servisi
ben doğrudan konteyner koymuyorum. Her
servisi ihtiyacım oluşturup
kullanıyorum. Oluştururken de network
managerı baseedden yolluyorum. Bakın
burada var instance olarak. Bunun amacı
da şu. Y sen bunu istersen kendin başka
bir şey de yollayabilirsin. Belki test
network manager yapacaksın bir şey bunu
öyle yolla. Yollamıyorsan da global
olanı kullan. Diyorum ki bu sayede temiz
bir kullanım elde ediyorum. Ardından da
buraya geldiğimde arkadaşlar benim
mesela diyelim ki bir e flightları
çekeceğim. Bir requestim var. Benim
aslında benim flight'larla ilgili
alakalı dediğim nokta arkadaşlar bakın
şimdi şurada ben be kendimi hazır ettim.
Bakın şurada benim 200 veren get flight
adı altında bir local hosta servisim var
aslında. Şu hatta şuradan eee local'ta
gidip istek atıyor olsam
Localos 8.000 açıktı herhalde yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam.
Kaçı açmışız? He 80 80 açmışız. İşte
şurada flights var. Bakın şu flights'a
gidip şuradan istek atarsam ve şunu
preti edersem bakın bana şurada şöyle
bir istek cevabı geliyor. Şu şimdi ben
bunu pars etmek için benim yapmam
gereken temel mantık şu. Ben kendi
modelime geldiğimde arkadaşlar öncelikle
modeli oluşturmam gerekiyor. Benim
modeli oluşturmak için de tekrardan
şuradan açacak olursam gitti o. Şuradan
açayım. Heh şuradan prit edeyim. Mesela
ben kendi modelimi oluştururken benim
kullanacaklarım nelerse onları
veriyorum. Mesela ben bunları
kullanacağım ve bunu kullanacağım için
benim oluşturmam gereken ana modelim bu.
Bunun içerisinde tabii success ve
message gibi ana base parameterlar var.
Bunlarla ilgili yönetim yapılır ama
sizin için şu an önemli olan bunları
kullanıp bunları set edip bunları
alabilmek. Şimdi bu noktada arkadaşlar
ben neyi alacaksam onu oluşturuyorum.
Yani benim aslında Fright Response model
tarzında hangi propertyleri alacaksam
onları alıp set edeceğim bir ana modelim
oluyor. Bunun da altında flight modelde
arrayım oluyor. Aslında invested ufak
bir yapı kuruyorum. Ve bunları kurarken
de arkadaşlar ben eğer benim network
managerımı kullanıyorsam mesela şu sent
requestti benim herhangi bir modelim
daima network manager'dan türey olması
lazım. Bunun amacı da tamamıy class
atmasın. Network manager dediğim
classımda benim to J'im ve from jim %100
olmak zorunda diye set ettiriyorum. Bu
sayede ben herhangi bir klasının nereden
geldiğini ve ne içerdiğini biliyorum.
Buradaki yapmaya çalıştığım şey basitçı.
Bunu yaptıktan sonra aslında network
manager sent dediğinde artık her şey çok
kolaylaşıyor. Diyorsun ki ben bunu
istiyorum ve bunu almak istiyorum. Bun
bunu veriyorum ve bunu almak istiyorum
dedikten sonrasında sana doğrudan bu
cevabı verip işte verdiğin response
modua göre sana burada set ettirip
döndürecek bir yapım var. Mesela şu send
request'in içerisine gidersen mesela bu
send request de burada tabii şeye koydu.
Önemli değil. Şuradan gidelim Product
Network Manager'a. Mesela bu send
request'in içerisine gidecek olursam bu
Veganon'dan gelen özelliğin içerisinde
şöyle çeşitli kullanımlar var. Mesela
bazen URC fix eklemek isteyebilirsin. Qu
parameter atmak isteyebilirsin.
Expression atmak iste. Bunların hepsi
burada var. Yani bu kullanımlar
sayesinde sen burayı istersen bunu
kullanırsın istersen de oradan eee
network manager erişirsin Vegana'ya.
Vegana'nın özelini kullanır kullanırsın.
Mesela diyelim yüzdelik göstermek
istiyorsun. Hepsi bu Veganada var. Şimdi
geldim geriye aslında benim temel olarak
yaptığım şey şu. Ben Jason Body'yi
buldum. Jason'yi bulduktan sonra gelecek
Jason Modyi. Şurada Jason Cellizable'a
çevirdim. Bu arada promptumun üzerinden
bunu yapabileceksiniz zaten. Jason'ı
verin. Size bunu modelleri oluşturacak.
Ben içerdiği dosyaları yazdım. İçerdiği
modelleri yazdım. Modelleri yazdıktan
sonrasında benim from to jon'ımı
çalıştırıyorum. Çalıştırdıktan sonra
bakın bana mesela bu ne? Product error
modelmiş. Bunu geç. Mesela benim ne var
burada? Şurada flight response modelim
var. Flight response modelimin
içerisinde arkadaşlar ben ilgili dosyamı
oluşturuyorum. oluşturduktan sonrasında
benim için otomatik generation troll
from jonları oluşuyor ve benim için
artık bu dosya tamamlayan hazır. Bakın
ben bunu yaptıktan sonra sendikten sonra
doğrudan bana bunun işte future e sealed
class olan hali geliyor olacak istersem.
Ya da arkadaşlar yine benzer bir
kullanımda aşağıda var. Bakın body'ye de
hani bodyye böyle paslamış ama bu
body'ye böyle paslanmaz. Normalde bunu
request mesela bunu da şöyle to'u
request parametre olması lazım bunun
mesela ki böyle böyle hiçbir için
vermeyin. Çünkü bunu böyle verirseniz
olmaz. Request parameter olarak eklemek
lazım bunu gibi bir kullanımla
arkadaşlar burayı bağlıyorsunuz. Yani
günün sonunda aslında yaptığınız şey
network merage oluşturmak. Amacımız
bütün projeler kullanılacak,
gelişebilir, değişebilir ve içerisine
bir şeyler ekleyebileceğim konteyneriz
bir yapıya entegre gitmek. Ardından
generic kullanıma bir selam vermek.
Generik kullanım sayesinde ben projemin
içerisinde rahat rahat ilerletebileceğim
bir yapıyı aldığımı düşünebilirsiniz. Ve
günün sonunda en son olarak da
arkadaşlar isteklerimi atıp isteklerimi
attıktan sonrasında kullanacağım. E ve
sadece hangisini istiyorsam neyi
vereceğim dedikten sonra e sealed
özelliğinde kullanarak da success false
doldurup bitireceğim bir yapı benimle
oluyor. Aynısı authentication service
için de geçerli. Hiçbir fark yok. Zaten
buralar artık tamamıy ve burası tamamıy
günün sonunda bitmiş oluyor. Burada
dikkat etmeniz gereken bir yapı. Network
manager oluştururken benim yapımda
error'u ben başta setiyorum. Çünkü bir
structuralı bir backendinizde daima
error modeller bir yapıda döner. Mesela
success, message, error, code details.
Bunu her yerde set etmezsin zaten. Bir
tane de set edersin ve sana döner.
Burada yaptığımız bize kazandığın da
avantaj ne biliyor musunuz? Bakın mesela
ben şu flight service'e geleyim. Ben
fold deyince on success'te ben ne
verdiysem ben onu geri alıyorum ve
burada bunları kullanabiliyorum. Bir de
on error'üm var ya on errorde bakın bana
gelen error dynamic veya bir generik bir
şey değil. Daha benim orada set ettiğim
bir error modelim dönüyor. Bu da benim
çok rahat bir şekilde çünkü bu errorda
çok hata yapılıyor. Doğrudan bulup
almamı sağlıyor. Bundan dolayı bu çok
güzel bir kullanım. Yani ben bu
kullanımı ve regzanayla bu yaptığım
yapıyı gerçekten seviyorum. Şimdi ben
burada gelip mesela işte atmışım mesela
artık bugünün sonunda flight servisimi
ben diyorum ki network back manager
setup local setmişim işte set ettikten
sonra flight servisim artık bunu zaten
doğrudan alıyor olacak çünkü artık
statik instance'tan dolayı ve ben
buradan istek attığımda buralara gidip
isteklerini atıp mesela bana diyelim ki
mesela arkadaşlar şunu debug yapayım
mesela bu debı yaptığımda mesela bana
buraya işlem bittiğini gösterecek işlem
bittiğinde mesela gördüğünüz gibi mesela
success'i alacağım data arrayimi
alacağım alacağım bunu artık uyayımda
istediğim şekil şekilde kullanıp eee
kullanıcıma bunu veriyor olacağım.
Aslında zaten buradaki eee temel
amacımız ve kullanımdaki yani yapı
olarak yapmak istediğimiz şey bu. Ben
burada gideceğim alacağım. Aldıktan
sonra UI bunu istediği şekilde
kullanabilir. İsterse alsın kendisi
dataya çevirip kullansın. İsterse
callback atsın isterse nasıl isteim yapı
tamamen bizim elimizde. Eee isterseniz
projenin network manager katmanın eski
hali olan versiyonu da var. Eski alan
versiyonu da kullanabilirsiniz projenin
içerisinde. Onu da göstereyim. Hatta şu
vegana da var arkadaşlar. Ben o ikisini
de seviyorum yerine göre. Mesela benim e
usage 1 bu. Usage 2 mesela usage 3
dediği nokta nerede? He mesela şey eee
cent request.
Ben birincisinde hiçbir şey kullanmazsam
şöyle oluyor arkadaşlar. Fold etmeden
kullandığım yapı. Mesela foldlu
kullandığım var. Bir de foldsuz
kullandığım yapı var. Fsuz kullandığım
yapıda şu. Direkt gelen response respons
is errorlar falan var. Oradan yakalamaya
çalışıyorum. Yani aslında eee foldsuz
olan yapıda her zaman için error da
dönüyor ama fold olan yapıda error falan
yok. Doğrudan response dediğin şey senin
istediğin alamadığın da burada. Bu daha
rahat ve daha yönetim esnekliğine sahip.
Yani aslında bugünün sonunda bu işi
bitirdiğinizde arkadaşlar beendiniz
hazır. İstediğinizi almış ve çok rahat
bir şekilde network managerlarınız neden
yaptığınızı bildiniz ve nelerini
koydunuz kodlarınızla birlikte sizin
olacak. Abstractionını yaptınız. Class
alt classlarını oluşturdunuz. Hangi
model istiyorsanız generation'ını
yaptınız. Eee servis classlarınızı
doldurdunuz ve burası artık sizin için
oldukça temiz ve bir şekilde ve gelişime
açık. projenizde yeni gelenlerine çok
rahat bir şekilde uyum sağlayacak
noktada hazır. Error falan işte default
parametreleri burada çok temiz bir
şekilde hazır. Hatta bunu yaptıktan
sonra ben işte flight list page'de falan
gittim. E bunları da burada arkadaşlar
sayfama göre dedim ki bu yaptığım yeni
göre factored. Bakın burada geldi mesela
flight list dedi. Bu local hepsi uçtu.
Direkt servisi çağladı. Servisten de get
flight dedi. Kodumu yazdım doldurdum
geçtim. Mesela eskiye göre temiz
tertemiz bu kullanım benimle arkadaşlar.
Eee, bunların içerisine buraya bağladım.
Burada
ekstra bilgilerden arkadaşlar yani bu
structure anladınız diyelim. Bakın
burada zaten benim size vermiş olduğum
dokümanın altındaki prompt'ı görecek
olursanız network layer promptını alıp
herhangi bir projeye verirseniz ya da
bakarsanız çok rahatlıkla bu yapıyı alıp
kendinize kullanabilirsiniz. Ekstraya
giderseniz arkadaşlar iki tane de
command sizde olacak. Bir tanesi maoid
nereden geldi ya? Mauroid gerek yok.
Flutter network generator. Şunu sileyim.
Bu maid başka. Flutter network
generator. Bu network manager katmanını
oluşturmak için yapıyor. E bu neymiş?
Flutter implement. Bunu fazladan yaptı.
Buna da bu eski değilse fazladan yaptı.
Yani bakın şu network generator'a
girerseniz arkadaşlar bu network
generator sizin için şunu yapıyor.
Gidiyor eee projenizdeki işte bu
generator yoksa bakın setup özelliğini
kullanıyor. Generator varsa Jason
response verirseniz buna göre modelinizi
oluşturuyor. Servis kısmınızı
oluşturuyor. İşte endp login. Yani bu
aslında sizin bütün ihtiyacınız olacak
şeyi tek promptla tek command koduyla
yapacak halde sizin elinizi alır. Bunu
kullanabilirsiniz. promptü kullanıp
kendinizi entegre edebilirsiniz ve
rahatlıkla entegre olursunuz projeye.
Burada ben bir script oluşturdum. Bu
script arkadaşlar bu build
dosyalarınızın, model dosyalarınızın
oluşması için bittikten sonra bunu
tekrar çağırmanız gerekiyor. Ya runner
watch kullanacaksınız veya buradan işte
elle tetikle edeceksiniz. Ben bunu da
severim çünkü watch kastırıyor bazen.
Son olarak burada önemli parametreden
bir tanesi bakın şu diamondır. Bunu
genelde çok kullanıyor olmaz. Siz Jason
Sizable işlemlerinizi yani aslında bir
generation işleminizi yaparken ne
yapacağını söyleyebiliyorsun. Ben buraya
gelip generation'ı işte sadece şu dosya
formatlarında yap demem çok önemli.
Çünkü bunu dediğim zaman gidip bütün
dosyaları aramıyor. Buna uyan
formatlarda Jon Generation çalışıyor. Bu
da bir proje için gerçekten önemli
noktalardan bir tanesi oluyor
arkadaşlar. Son olarak PU Spect'e
vaganımı ekledim. annotationlarımı
koydum ve günün sonuna baktığınızda
arkadaşlar tertemiz e projeyi çok ileri
götürebilecek, her şeyini içeren e bütün
yapılarına sizi destekleyecek ve dediğim
gibi herhangi bir T'nın rahat rahat
testini de yazabileceğiniz ki burada
gördüğünüz bütün testler çalışmaktadır.
Eee şuradan geleyim mesela flight
service, out service hepsi burada
çalışmakta. Bunları entegre edip
kullanabileceğiniz bir yapı sizinle
arkadaşlar. Ondan dolayı ben burayı
dediğim gibi oldukça mesela şu senaryoyu
göstereyim. Mesela errora geldi diyelim.
Mesela error güzel oluyor. Mesela şurada
buna gelmemiş mi? Bir tanesinin error
geliyordu şurada ama bakalım hangisi
düşüyordu. Şu olabilir.
Ha mesela error'a geldi. Bakın status
code doğrudan aldım. En çok önemli
bunlar. Error. Bunda backend dönüyor.
Tabii backend size bu yapıda dönüyor.
Buradan tak diye alıyorsunuz. İşte
bunlar dynamiklikten falan filan oldukça
uzak. Tertemiz bir şey. Yani siz bekendi
bana bu formatta döndürdiğinizde bütün
isteklerinizde tek kalemle
alabileceğiniz bir yapı sizinle oluyor
arkadaşlar.
demiş. Olayım. Eee, bu sayede oldukça
bence önemli. Bütün projelerde
kullanabileceğiniz bir re factor daha
daha tamamlamış olduk. Eee, şuradan
geleyim. Tod'dan da bir katman daha
atıyorum buraya. V8 network layer,
service layer ve model layer diyeyim
şuraya. Bu da bizim için bitmiş olsun.
Bunu da arkadaşlar yine buradan
commitledim.
Şuradan yolluyorum.
Oluşturdum.
Siz de rahat rahat bunu projenizde
kullanıp kendinize alabilirsiniz. Umarım
hem fikir geçmiştir, hem yapıyı
anlamışsınızdır, hem de promptlarla
vesaire çok rahatlıkla kendi projenizde
bunu yani bu temiz network manager işte
coding mimarı olarak güçlü işte her
yerde kullanabileceğiniz eee her anda
rahatlıkla gel yani ekleyebileceğiniz ve
generik olarak kullanabileceğiniz en
önemli kısımlardan bir tanesi bu.
yenarık bir şekilde hani böyle tek tek
dikler olmadan tık tık ne nerede nasıl
kullanacağını kimsenin hata yapmayacağı
ve kimsenin dışarı çıkamayacağı yani o
çalışma arkadaşlarınızı doğru yerde
tutabileceğiniz bir yapıyı burada
kullanmış oluyorsunuz dediğim gibi
tekrardan arkadaşlar işinize yarar
umarım bayramlarınızı kutluyorum
tekrardan gidenlerinize Allah rahmet
eylesin kanalların ellerinden öpüyorum
kendinize çok iyi bakın bir sonraki
içeriklerde artık tekrardan görüşmek
üzere kendinize iyi bakın dostlar